ja willkommen bei einer neuen Sendung
von filocast wieder zum Thema digitale
Philosophie wir hatten schon in den
letzten Sendungen das Thema Bitcoin
behandel dann mache ich oben rechts
einen Link rein wir hatten das Thema
Metaversum behandelt machen wir auch
oben rechts ein Link rein heute geht es
um das Thema blockchain ein riesen Thema
ein Thema wo nicht viele genau wissen
was ist es eigentlich und ich freue mich
heute mein Experten Marcel uhrenschal
wieder im Studio zu haben hallo Marcel
hallo freut mich auch schön dass du da
bist ja wir fangen gleich mal an die
Frage die erste Frage was ist eigentlich
blockchain kannst du uns das mal konkret
zu erklären was hat es damit auf sich wo
begegnen uns blockchain Technologien
einfach mal diese generelle Frage was
ist
genau also traditioneller Weise kennt
man blockchain vor allem von der von
Bitcoin der dezentralen dezentralen
monetären System und was man sich
drunter vorstellen kann wenn man gar
keine Ahnung hat dann ist blockchain
nichts anderes als eine Datenbank und es
ist eine Datenbank die dezentral ist
global dezentralisiert verwaltet wird
und keine
zentrale Instanz hat die über den
Verlauf oder den Informationsgehalt
dieser Datenbank bestimmen kann sondern
die der Wahrheitswert und
Informationsgehalt die
Validierung der Transaktionen am
Beispiel von Bitcoin könnte man das so
beschreiben findet dezentral statt und
genau und eine andere Eigenschaft die
hinzukommt ist dass die blockchain
chronologisch ist eine chronologische
Datenbank was das was das heißt bedeutet
die
blockchain bei Bitcoin zum Beispiel
ist eine Kette an Blogs mit
Informationen drin über die
Transaktionen die alle 10 Minuten im
Schnitt entstehen und daher kommt auch
das Bild diese Metapher also blockchain
ist auch ein metaphorischer Begriff um
etwas zu beschreiben was da in diesem
ganzen in dieser Bitcoin Technologie
sozusagen vorhanden ist und das ist eben
die chronologische Anordnung von Blogs
mit Informationen die verkettet sind
ineinander und verkettet heißt auch also
ich reversibel man kann sie nicht mehr
verändern und
genau rückwirkend nicht mehr verändern
dann gibt es Kritiker die sagen doch das
geht schon wenn man irgendwie genug
Energie Aufwand zum Beispiel leistet und
dann die blockchain verändern könnte
indem man sie hackt oder so aber die
bitcoin blockchain ist so gestaltet und
das ist das spannende dass es
spieltheoretisch fast unmöglich ist oder
keinen Sinn macht eine Veränderung
vorzunehmen um zum Beispiel Profite für
einen selber herauszuholen indem ich
sage Jörg du hast mir jetzt zehn
Bitcoins geschickt obwohl du es nicht
gemacht hast weil in dem Moment wo ich
versuche den Informationsgehalt von der
Bitcoin blockchain zu verändern und zu
korrumpieren hat Bitcoin sein Wert
verloren komplett weil sie es nicht mehr
vertrauenswürdig ist das heißt dieses
dezentral organisierte Netzwerk an der
Validierung von Transaktionen schafft
auch großes Vertrauen durch diese
Unveränderbarkeit der vergangenen
Geschehnisse ja vielen Dank du hast hier
schon wichtigen philosophischen Begriff
ins macht Vertrauen also was wie
Sicherheit Objektivität das sind
natürlich jetzt auch gleich
philosophisch interessante Themen jetzt
wenn man mal philosophischen Blick auf
die blockchain werfen wollen dann könnte
man sich überlegen kann man vielleicht
mit blockchains auch sowas wie
Gerechtigkeit und Vertrauen
institutionalisieren unabhängig von der
Zuverlässigkeit von einzelnen
Institutionen oder auch Personen es
hängt ja nicht mehr in einzelnen
Personen ob das ganze System
funktioniert es hängt auch nicht an der
europäischen Zentralbanken es ist keine
Zentralbanken eine dezentralbank was
hältst du davon wenn man jetzt versuchen
würde blockchain philosophisch als eine
Struktur eine dezentrale Struktur der
Gerechtigkeit und auch der Objektivität
für unser menschliches Zusammenleben zu
bestimmen
aber ich glaube objektivität ist in
irgendeiner Form möglich die Frage ist
ob es erwünscht ist oder oder ob man ob
wir das überhaupt haben wollen weil es
natürlich dann sehr normativen Charakter
vielleicht bekommt in der Art so es gibt
nur noch eine Wahrheit wenn wir sagen
das ist die Datenbank auf die wir uns
jetzt einigen
dann hat es halt episomologisch so ein
bisschen dieses es gibt nur noch diese
eine Wahrheit und keine Alternativen was
auf der einen Seite etwas ist was wir
uns wünschen also auch im Thema in
diesem ganzen Thema was wir seit 2015
haben bei dieser Thematik von Fakten
wünschen wir uns keine
Alternativlosigkeit und gleichzeitig ist
sie aber auch wissenschaftlich
betrachtet total wichtig weil man ja
immer sagen kann naja vielleicht wissen
wir nicht alles in dem jetzigen Moment
und in der Zukunft wissen wir neuartige
Dinge haben neue Erkenntnisse und können
dadurch sozusagen unseren Wissensstand
erweitern
dementsprechend ist Objektivität die
Frage ist es erwünscht glaube ich so
also ein bisschen ambivalent zu ja oder
nein und möglich ist es bei Bitcoin aber
zeigt sich es ist halt für ein ganz
bestimmten Bereich möglich im Falle von
Bitcoin für ein monetäres Geldsystem da
ist es sozusagen ist es so stark
begrenzt dieser dieses Informationsfeld
und zwar Transaktionen finden also ist
es sind Informationen über Transaktion
und Informationen über Besitz und nicht
Besitz von Bitcoin und das war es auch
schon
es wäre total mutig und ein total großer
Sprung jetzt zu sagen wow wir können
alles in den blockchain packen alle
Informationsgehalt das ist eine
Herausforderung auch ein geistige
Experiment finde ich wo womit man sich
beschäftigen sollte und womit sich auch
viele blockchain andere
blockchain-projekte beschäftigen
konkrete Anwendungsfälle findet es aber
eher in so Beispiel wie Lieferketten zum
Beispiel
ja auch charakteristisch schon Ketten
sind und da diese blockchain-charakter
auch natürlich wieder vorkommt wo man
einfach sehen möchte okay was ist wann
genau passiert und ähm können wir das
nachvollziehen und vielleicht sogar
verbessern also Lieferketten sind auch
ganz Kombination Beispiel wo es auch
schon jetzt in der Industrie verwendet
wird ja jetzt hast du schon ein Thema
gebracht wo es Verwendung findet und
jetzt setzen wir mal das Wort wo könnte
es in Zukunft so als Ausblick noch
Verwendung finden ich habe mal gehört
dass auch
notarielle Tätigkeiten oder
Beurkundungen Beglaubigungen überhaupt
Vertrauens Prozesse die
vertrauensbasierte Prozesse offizielle
Prozesse durch die blockchain gar nicht
mehr in einzelne Institutionen oder auch
Personen gebunden sein müssen sondern
dass das alles eben über diese
dezentrale Struktur organisiert werden
kann verlieren wir vielleicht auch ganz
viele Berufe durch die blockchain alles
was so um Beamtentum geht um offizielle
Bestätigungen
also wenn wenn notari ihren Job
verlieren sind ja nicht so viel Leute
glaube ich aber
ansonsten in dem ganzen bürokratischen
Apparat könnte es sein dass wir da auf
jeden Fall disruptive Momente erleben
vielleicht noch mal auf dem auf diese
vertragsbegrifflichkeit zu sprechen zu
kommen Smart contracts ist so ein
Begriff der mit der ethereum blockchain
aufgekommen ist und beschreibt eben ein
ein vertragsprozess der ohne Mittelsmann
funktioniert das ist nämlich das
spannende also es ist auf einmal möglich
innerhalb man muss es auch immer sehen
so es gibt diese blockchain diese Welt
innerhalb der blockchain und dann die
Welt da draußen sozusagen und smart
contracts funktionieren gerade besonders
gut innerhalb der blockchain wo wir
große technologische aber auch
episomologische Probleme haben bei
blockchains ist wie kriegt man einen
Informationsgehalt von der Außenwelt in
die blockchain rein
bei Bitcoin haben wir einen
geschlossenes System um es mal so zu
beschreiben weil es ja alles
Transaktionen innerhalb der Bitcoin
blockchain sind und Informationen
innerhalb der Bitcoin blockchain wer hat
wie viel Bitcoin das war's das macht
Bitcoin aber so
zukunftsorientiertere Projekte die dann
sozusagen wobei Bitcoin auch
zukunftsorientiert ist aber ich meine
nur andere Anwendungsfälle da möchte man
dann auf einmal sowas machen wie hey ich
möchte den CO2 Ausstoß von Firmen in
ihren Lieferketten irgendwie Objektiv
nachvollziehen und das innerhalb in
durch einen blockchain transparent
machen ich möchte CO2 Ausstoß
transparent gestalten weil blockchainst
und transparent und CO2-Zertifikate
haben so eine grundsätzliche
Intransparenz so ein bisschen das ist
schwer nachzuvollziehen wer stellt sie
aus und wie könnten wir das nicht lösen
mit einer blockchain aber dann kommt man
schnell zum Problem von Außenwelt wo
alles passieren kann wo zentral
Institutionen gibt wo es vielleicht auch
so freundschaftsdienstleistungen gibt
zwischen Firmen und ähm und und und und
das kann man nicht kontrollieren oder
oder es ist auch nicht dezentral
organisiert oder so in der wie wie es
beim Bitcoin der Fall wäre genau und
dann ist immer die Frage so wie kriegen
wir den Informationsgehalt ohne äh also
sozusagen wahrheitsgetreu in diesem
blockchain wegen rein das ist ein
Problem Smart contracts können aber die
innerhalb der blockchain stattfinden
sehr gut schon dieses
mittelmannsfreie Vertragsablauf die
können diesen ganz gut abbilden und auch
gewährleisten also wir könnten zum
Beispiel ein Handel betreiben auf der
Serien blockchain ich schicke dir ein
witziges NFT und du zahlst mir dafür
halt einen bestimmten Geldbetrag und das
können wir ohne Mittelsmann durch ein
smartphone- gewährleisten der nichts
anderes macht als das NFT eine Box zu
tun dein Geld in der Box zu tun dann zu
überprüfen durch einen Algorithmus ja
beides ist da und dann sendet er das
automatisch an uns jeweiliges weiter so
keiner betrügen kann und das ist eine
riesiger Schritt so das ist spannend da
sagst du betrug wird
eingeschränkt und Vertrauen wird
objektiviert und zwar ohne Mittelsmann
oder mittelsfrau das ist schon exakt
ganz wichtig zu sein das heißt die neuen
Technologien die können auch sowas wie
Verbindlichkeit schaffen und auch
Konflikte letztendlich vermeiden helfen
durch Algorithmen durch Strukturen die
einfach auf Gerechtigkeit
ausgerichtet sind wo der menschliche
Faktor
Bestechung Betrug parteichigkeit und so
weiter wo der einfach wegfällt das ist
ja das Ideal der Gerechtigkeit der
Objektivität der Unparteilichkeit was
man durch die Technologie neu
realisieren kann und und das wollte ich
vorhin auch Fragen also was für ein
gerechtigkeitsverständnis hast du jetzt
da so ein also welches grobe
gerechtigkeitsverständnis hast du ja
also Unparteilichkeit wäre so mein Punkt
also keine Sympathien weil da wo
Menschen im Spiel sind da gibt es immer
Sympathie in der kann man selten so ein
rein objektiven Blick drauf werfen
ja das wäre so eine Möglichkeit ja dass
man sagt die blockchain als objektives
gerechtigkeitsverfahren ist es ja nur
ein Verfahren Gerechtigkeit wird da noch
sehr formal bestimmt Gerechtigkeit als
Tugend ist natürlich damit nicht gemeint
blockchain ist keine Tugend aber es ist
eine Struktur die vielleicht auch
Gerechtigkeit erst ermöglicht kann man
auch sagen die Gerechtigkeit ist noch
zugrunde liegt wo noch mehr passieren
muss damit wirklich von Gerechtigkeit
gesprochen werden kann das nur mit Blick
auf eine bessere Welt eine bessere
Gesellschaft das sind Technologien die
sicherlich dazu beitragen können wenn
man sie richtig einsetzt ne die tun ja
nicht von selbst ausgerechtigkeit
erzeugen sondern wir Menschen müssen sie
wieder einsetzen programmieren
einstellen für Orten damit sowas
überhaupt dann stattfinden kann ja
Marcel jetzt haben wir hier noch einen
guten Ausblick gegeben was damit alles
möglich ist wir haben jetzt doch denke
ich gut herausbekommen wie wir die neuen
Technologien auch philosophisch
verstehen können und welche Ergebnisse
sind welche Bezugspunkte sich hier
gerade auch in der politischen
Philosophie ergeben Marcel nochmal
vielen Dank für deine Expertise und wir
freuen uns auch über Kommentare unten
nach der Diskussion im Video auf Youtube
wir sind ganz offen für weitere
Vorschläge genau und vielleicht könnt
ihr auch noch mal kurz sagen was der
spannendste Anwendungsfall für
blockchain ist von dem ihr gehört habt
das wäre auch spannend